ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้รับน้องเรียมหาสวัสดี
น้องเล็กนักเรียนด้วยครับนักเรียนทุกคน
สวัสดีครับเย้
วันนี้วันนี้เราอ่าเพียบที่
กลับน้องเรียมกลับมาเจอกับนักเรียนทุกคน
อีกแล้วในวันนี้เรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกันเย้
เย้เรียนอ่ะวันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันที่เท่า
ไหร่ครับเนี้ยวันนี้วันที่ 24 ค่ะวันนี้
วันที่ 24 ใช่ไหมนะนี่เบียร์ที่เอาปฏิทิน
มาเอาปฏิทินมาด้วยครับวันนี้วันที่ 24
ใช่ไหม
หายไปกลับมาแล้วอ้วนวันนี้วันที่ 24 นี้
ครับวันที่ 24 เดือนเดือนยายนต์ยนต์
เหมือนเดิมอย่างเป็นเดือนกันยายนอยู่นะ
ครับเดือนนี้วันที่ 24 กันยายนวันอะไร
ครับวันนี้วันศุกร์ 5 วันนี้เป็วันศุกร์
แย่วันนี้วันศุกร์หน้าวันทุก 5 วันศุกร์
ที่ 24 กันยายนปีอะไรครับ
ปีคศ
2021 ใช่แล้วครับแล้วปีพศอะไรเอ่ย
2564 ก็ปีพตตพุทธศักราช
2560  4 ว้าวว้าวงั้นเมตรแล้วตอนนี้วัน
นี้กี่โมงครับ
กี่โมงแล้วนี้
10 โมงแล้วค่ะ 10 โมงมี 16  10 โมงมี
เข็มสั้น
เกือบ
10:00 นใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะ 10 โมง 20 ลง
ร้องหน้าเข็มยาวจะอยู่นี้โอเค 10 โมงตรง
อ่า 10 โมงตรงไหนครับอา
10:00 นเป็นเข้า 10:00 น
10:00 นมีเลข 1 นะนี่เล็กๆโอเค 10 โมง
ตรงกว่านี้เพียงตีจะผ่าทุกคนไป
กินข้าวไปกินข้าวกันก็นี้วันนี้วันนี้ 10
โมงแล้วน้องเรียนกินข้าวหรือยังครับ
กินข้าวตอนเช้าตอนเช้ากินข้าวหรือยังครับ
ตอนเช้ากินข้าวแล้วค่ะพ่อกินข้าวแล้วเฮีย
ตีก็กินข้าวแล้วอ่านี่คือข้าวคนไทยคนไทย
เรากินข้าวน่ากินข้าวนี่มีข้าวข้าวได้เรา
กินข้าวกันเป็นประจำกินข้าวทุกทุกวันเลย
อ่ะคนไทยกินข้าวนะครับข้าวใส่จานไว้นี่
ข้าวอยู่ในจานนะนี่คือจานจานจานข้าวอ่ะ
อาจารย์ข้าวใช่ครับแต่เมื่อเช้าเมื่อเช้า
เพียงตีไปกินข้าวแกงมา
เข้าแก่ๆครับเข้าแก่แกงก็คือสิ่งที่เรา
เอามากินกับข้าวอ่านี่ครับนี่เป็นร้านแพง
นี่นี่คือแกงแกงแกะหมายถึงสิ่งที่เราเอา
มากินคู่กับข้าว
ครับกับ
ข้าวมีแกงกินอะไรค่ะอ๋ออ๋อไม่ดีกินแกงกิน
แกงส้ม
นี่
แกงส้มมีคือแกงส้มในแกงส้มใส่อะไรบ้าง
ครับน้องเรียมเห็นอะไรในแกงส้มที่คิดเห็น
กุ้งกุ้งอ่ะอ่ะนี่ครับแกงส้มกุ้งหน้าแล้ว
ก็มีผักฮิผักอยู่ด้วยอ่าแกงส้มผักนะครับ
อ่านี่ผักหลายอย่างที่คนไทยเอามาแกงนะ
ครับมีผักหลายอย่างเลยอย่างอันนี้นี่คือ
ดอกแคดอกแคเป็นดอกไม้ชนิดนึงดอกไม้ชนิด
นึงกินได้กินได้คนให้เอามาแกงแกงส้มดอกแค
ว้าวอร่อยด้วยอร่อยด้วยค่ะอย่างดีแล้ว
โอเคหาแล้วนอกจากแกงส้มแล้วนะเดี๋ยววัน
นี้พี่จะแนะนำแกงเขียวหวานด้วยนะฮะนี่
ครับนักเรียนนักเรียนคนไหนเคยกินเคยกิน
แกงเขียวหวานบ้างน้องเรียนเคยกินด้วยใช่
ไหม
ว่าแกไงค่ะแกงเขียวหวานรสชาติเป็นยังไง
บ้างครับน้องเรียมก็จะมีมีรสชาติหวานหอม
มีรสหวานใช่ไหมเพราะว่าชื่อแกงเขียวหวาน
ก็จึงมีรสหวานหน้าแล้วก็มีสีเขียวด้วยมี
สีเขียวนี่สีเขียวอ่อนๆสีเขียวอ่อนไส้ก็
เลยเรียกว่าแกงเขียวหวาน
แกงเขียวหวานอร่อยแล้วกินแกงเขียวหวานกับ
ข้าวใช่ไหม
ค่ะเห็นแล้วก็ได้แกงเขียวหวานมีอะไรคะใน
แกงเขียวหวานอ้ามีมะเขือนี่มีมะเขือหน้า
แล้วก็มีพริกมีพริกก็จะมีรสเผ็ดนิดหน่อย
แกงเขียวหวานเผ็ดนิดหน่อยเผ็ดไม่เยอะเห็ด
ไม่เยอะชายเพชรนิดเดียว 5  7 นิดหน่อยมี
มะเขือแล้วก็มีอันนี้เป็นไก่ไก่ไก่
5 ไก่ก็ตกๆหาไก่เอาเอามาแกงเขียวหวานฮ่า
ๆๆฮ่าๆๆ
บางทีบางทีเราก็เอาหมูแกงเขียวหวานหมู
ด้วยเหมือนกันใช่
หมู 5 ใช้ครับหมูอู๊ดอู๊ด I  would ๆใช่
แล้วอ้าๆหมูแกงเขียวหวานหมูทรายครับแล้ว
ก็อ่าบางทีคนไทยก็จะนิยมมากๆเลยเอาปลามา
แกงปลาตาชายคนไทยกินปลาเยอะเพราะว่า
ประเทศไทยมีมีมีแม่น้ำที่มีปลาอยู่ในแม่
น้ำเยอะเลยมีทะเลมีทะเลก็มีปลาด้วยใช่มี
ปลาที่น้องเรียนวาดให้ดู 5 แกงเขียวหวาน
ป่า
ได้ครับเดี๋ยวพี่แนะนำ
อ่าแกงจืดบ้างนี่แกงจืดอันนี้ไม่เผ็ดอัน
นี้ไม่เผ็ดอะนักเรียนนักเรียนหลายๆคนกิน
ได้ครับอันนี้ไม่เผ็ดไม่เผ็ดกินได้อันนี้
เป็นแกงเพื่อเราไม่ใส่พริกใช่ครับไม่ใส่
พริกไม่ใส่พริกเด็กๆเด็กๆก็กินได้หน้ามัน
ไม่เผ็ดอะ
หมอค่ายาไม่ใส่ปิ๊กนี่ไงเราไม่ใส่พริกอ้ะ
แกงจืดไม่ใส่พริก
5 สำหรับนักเรียนหลายๆคนหรือว่าน้อง
เรียมเวลาที่ไปตามร้านอาหารของไทยนัก
เรียนนักเรียนแล้วก็น้องเรียมจะเห็นสิ่ง
นี้ครับนี่
อันนี้คือ
น้ำปลาแล้วก็พริกง่ายอยู่ในจานเราเรียก
ว่าพริกน้ำปลาหน้าคนไทยชอบกินเผ็ดเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเพราะฉะนั้นต้องมีพริกน้ำก็หาอยู่
ด้วยอ้าจะได้เพิ่มรสชาติเผ็ดแล้วก็รสชาติ
เค็มจากน้ำปลาเข้าไปด้วยอ่ะเพิ่มความ
อร่อยเพิ่มออกอร่อยน้องเรียมชอบกินเผ็ด
ไหมครับ
ชอบค่ะชอบกินเอ็ด
ชอบเห็ดอ๋อเคเฮียตีก็ชอบกินเผ็ดเหมือนกัน
แล้วนะก็เรียนล่ะครับนักเรียนชอบกินเผ็ด
ไหมขี้ในคอมเม้นให้พี่ถ้าพี่กับน้องเรียน
รู้หน่อยนะว่าชอบกินเห็ดไหมหรือไม่ชอบไม่
ชอบเผ็ดอ่ะฮ่าๆๆโอเคอะนี่คือพริกน้ำปลา
หน้าปิดน้ำปลาแล้วๆเดี๋ยวอาตอนนี้
อันนั้นคือเมื่อเช้าที่อ่ะที่ไปกินมาแล้ว
ใช่ไหมเดี๋ยวตอนค่ะอย่างนี้ตอนเที่ยงตอน
เที่ยงเดี๋ยวเราไปกินอะไรกันดีครับตอน
เที่ยงอ่ะตอนเที่ยงก็คือตอนนี้นี่เที่ยง
ตอนเที่ยงนะครับ 12:00 น
ใช่เอาก็จะไปกินข้าวเที่ยงก็ไปกินข้าว
เที่ยงใช่ไหมหน้าถูกต้องครับเดี๋ยวตอน
เที่ยงพี่จะพาน้องเรียมกับนักเรียนทุกคน
ไปกินข้าวเที่ยงกันไปที่ร้านร้านอาหารตาม
สั่งนี้ร้าน
ร้านตามสั่งแปลว่าเราแต่ว่าน้องเรียมแต่
ว่านักเรียนทุกคนต้องสั่ง
สั่งคนที่ทำอาหารเนี่ยสั่งเนี่ยสั่งคนทำ
อาหารว่าจะกินอะไรจะกินอะไรอาหารตามสั่ง
อ่าใช่ครับโอเคเดี๋ยวเราไปดูเมนูอาหารตาม
สั่งว่ามีอะไรบ้างที่เพื่อที่จะแนะนำนัก
เรียนแล้วก็นักเรียนในวันนี้นะครับอ่ะ
อย่างแรกที่จะถามอะไรคะอ้าเครียดพี่สั่ง
อะไรเดี๋ยวตีคิดว่าเบียร์พี่จะสั่งข้าว
ผัดน้าสั่งข้าวผัดนี่ครับเป็นข้าวเอาข้าว
มาผัดหน้าเอาข้าวมาผัดในกระทะผัดผัดๆเข้า
ผ่านนี้ไม่เผ็ดไม่เผ็ดนักเรียนทุกคนกิน
ได้ 5 น้องเรียมเกาะกินได้เพราะว่ามันไม่
เผ็ดหน้าเราไม่ใส่พริกใช่ไม่ใส่เราไม่ใส่
ปิ๊กมันไม่เผ็ดคะแล้วก็เขาผัดอันนี้น่ะ
ที่พี่เอารูปมาให้ดูรูปนี้เป็นข้าวผัด
กุ้งข้าวผัดกุ้งอาร์ๆเป็นข้าวผัดแล้วก็
ใส่ไปหน้าเป็นข้าวผัดกุ้งแอปแต่ถ้านัก
เรียนหรือว่าน้องเรียมไม่ชอบกุ้งก็สามารถ
สั่งได้สั่งเป็นข้าวผัดอย่างอื่นได้อย่าง
เช่นอ้ะไม่เอากุ้งนะเอาหมูแทนนี่นี่เป็น
ข้าวผัดหมูใส่หมูลงไปแทนเขาก็จะเอาหมูใส่
เข้าไปนะครับแล้วก็ไม่ใส่กุ้งอ่าไม่ใส่
กุ้งเป็นข้าวผัดหมูอ่าก็ได้เหมือนกันนะ
ครับแล้วถ้าถ้าเรียงอยากกินข้าวผัดไก่นะ
คะอ่ะถ้าจะกินก็ผัดไก่เราก็สั่งว่าขอข้าว
ผัดไก่ขอก็ผัดไก่ครับขอข้าวผัดไก่ค่ะได้
เลยอ้าเขาก็จะไม่ใส่ไม่ใส่หมูไม่ใส่กุ้ง
แต่ใส่ไก่หน้าตาเป็นข้าวผัดไก่อ่ะได้
เหมือนกันนะหรือถ้านักเรียนบางคนนะครับ
ไม่ชอบกินหมูไม่ชอบกินไก่ชอบกินกุ้งก็
สามารถสั่งเป็นอย่างอื่นได้สั่งเป็นข้าว
ผัดป่าก็ได้หน้าเป็นข้าวผัดปลาอ่านี่เอา
ปลาใส่เข้าไปแทนไม่เอากุ้งหาก็อร่อย
เหมือนกันน่าอร่อยเหมือนกันถ้าเดียวไม่
กินไม่กินเนื้อสัตว์ไม่กินกุ้งไม่กินปลา
ไม่กินหมูไม่กินเหล้านะคะอ่ะก็สั่งข้าว
ผัด
อย่างเดียวเขาก็จะใส่ไข่มาให้ไข่นี่เขาจะ
ใส่ไข่มาให้ไข่ไข่แบบนี้ครับไข่น่าเป็น
ไข่ใส่ไข่มาในข้าวผัดข้าวผัดไข่ก็คือไม่
ใส่หมูไม่ใส่กุ้งไม่ใส่ปลาไชส์อาหารมีแต่
ถ้าน้องเรียนไม่กินไข่
ถ้าแบบนั้นต้องกินข้าวเปล่าครับเอาเปล่า
ไม่ใส่อะไร
เข้าสวยเห้ยข้าวเปล่าเข้าเปล่ากินข้าว
เปล่าๆแบบนี้อ้าแบบนี้คือค่ะไอ้มีอะไรไม่
อร่อยไม่อร่อยเข้าเปล่าจืดแล้วโอเคอ่ะถ้า
ไม่อยากกินข้าวผัดเดี๋ยวพี่อาชีพฮาไปสั่ง
ไปกินอย่างอื่นๆกินผัดกระเพราอ่าผัดผัก
เข้าออกดีไหมดีมั้ยนี่เลยแอบนี่ผัดกับเขา
ว้าวดูแล้วน่าจะเผ็ดน่าจะไปเก็บ
เราสามารถสั่งสั่งคนผัดได้บอกว่าอ้ะเผ็ด
เทนนิสเดียวเผ็ดนิดเดียวพริก 1 เมตรพริก 2
เม็ดได้เห็ดน้อยหรือเผ็ดมากได้หน้าอันนี้
เรียกว่าผัดกระเพราาามีใบกระเพราจะมี
กลิ่นหอมกลิ่นหอมใบกระเพราเวลาที่เราเวลา
ที่อาดมที่หายก็จะมีปิ่นไปกระเพราเป็นผัด
กระเพราหมูสับผัดกระเพราหมูอะนี่เป็น
เนื้อหมูแต่เหมือนเดิมครับเหมือนเดิมเลย
ถ้าน้องเรียมหรือถ้านักเรียนไม่ชอบกินหมู
ก็สามารถเปลี่ยนเป็นกระเพราปลากระเพรา
กุ้งได้เหมือนกันนะแต่อันนี้นี่เบียร์
เห็นอันนี้นี้อันนี้ไข่ดาวใช่ครับอันนี้
คือไข่ดาวใช่มีไข่ดาวเวลาที่เรากินผัด
กระเพราเนี่ยอันกระเพรามันก็จะเผ็ดใช่
มั้ยเผ็ดเราก็จะสั่งไข่ดาวด้วยไข่ดาวไม่
เผ็ดเอามากินคู่กันหน้ากินคู่กับผัด
กระเพราอะมีใครดาวหรือถ้าอ้าเราไม่ชอบไข่
ดาวนี่นี่เป็นไข่ดาวมีไข่ดาวนะครับอันนี้
เป็นไข่เจียวหน้านี้เราเรียกเดียวให้ครับ
มากินคู่กับผัดกระเพราได้เหมือนนี้นะครับ
อ่าไข่เจียวก็ไม่เผ็ดไม่เผ็ดนักเรียนทุก
คนกินได้เด็กๆเด็กๆก็กินได้เหมือนกันใช่
อาหารน้องเรียนชอบกินไข่ดาวหรือชอบกินไข่
เจียวครับเตรียมชอบกินไข่ดาว
เฮียตีก็ชอบกินไข่ดาวเหมือนกันเพราะว่า
ไข่ดาวทำง่ายทำง่ายๆครับง่ายกว่าไข่เจียว
โอเคอ่ะเมื่อกี้นี้ถ้าเราไม่ชอบกินผัด
กระเพราหมูใช่ไหมเราก็เปลี่ยนเป็นกระเพรา
ไก่ได้ก็สั่งว่า
ขอขออะไรครับอ่าน้องเรียนสั่งให้หน่อย
ขอกระเพราไก่ไม่เผ็ดอ๋อหาใช่ขอกระเพราไก่
ไม่เห็ดอ่ะเอาไข่ดาวด้วยไหมครับ
เอาไข่ดาวด้วยครั้งอ้อนี่ก็ขอกระเพราไก่
ไข่ดาวด้วยโอเคไม่เผ็ดนะไม่เผ็ดมากเผ็ด
นิดเดียวแค่สั่งแบบนี้เลยอะนักเรียนก็จะ
ได้กระเพราไก่ไข่ดาวนี่ค่ะเตรียมเตรียม
สั่งสั่งได้สั้นกว่านี้นะคะขอลาครับคนไทย
ชอบก็พูดสั้นๆใช่ไหมโอเคสั่งแบบไหนครับก็
สั่งสั้นๆ
กระเพราไก่ไข่ดาวอ๋อ
อ่ะๆเอาไก่ไข่ดาวไม่เผ็ดอ๋อกระเพราไก่ไข่
ดาวไม่เผ็ดหนึ่งที่อ้า 1 จานพ่อไก่ไข่ดาว
ไม่เผ็ด 1 จานนะโอเคอ่าก็จะได้กระเพราไก่
มาหรือถ้าไม่อยากได้กระเพราไก่ล่ะอ้าบาง
ทีเราอาจจะอยากกินปลาแล้วไม่อยากกินไก่ก็
สั่งกะเพราปลาก็ได้เหมือนกันนะครับหน้า
หรือว่าเป็นกระเพราไลค์อันนี้หน่อยครับ
ค่ะขอต้อนลาวพ่อประเทศไทยติดทะเลประเทศ
ไทยติดทะเลด้วยเพราะฉะนั้นประเทศไทยก็จะ
มีอาหารทะเลด้วยมีพระมือปลาหมึกก็เอามา
ผัดกระเพราได้นะกระเพราปลาหมึกไข่ดาวอ้า
ไม่เผ็ดเป็น a แล้วถ้าเรียงอยากกินทุก
อย่างทั้งปลาหมึกทั้งหมูปลา
ไก่อ๋ออ๋อถ้าอย่างไรเราเรียกว่าเอาทุก
อย่างมารวมกันมารวมกันน่ะเรียกว่ารวม Mix
หน้าต้องสั่งว่ากระเพรารวมมิตรหน้าไข่ดาว
ก็เราก็จะได้กระเพราหมูไก่ปลาๆเสมอรวมกัน
ทุกอย่างลงมาในจานเดียวลงมาในหนึ่งจานทุก
ทุกอย่างรวมมิตรอ่ะกระเพรารวมมิตร 1 จาน
แต่น้าเคระห์มีว้าวอย่ากินเยอะเลยเนี่ย
เรานี่หากินหลายอย่างอ่ะอยากกินหลาย
อย่าโอเคดีครับเดี๋ยวมีอะไรคะเพียบ
ผัดกระเพรานอกจากข้าวผัดแล้วในร้านอาหาร
ตามสั่งเนี่ยยังมีอาหารที่น่าสนใจอยู่อีก
นะครับเดี๋ยวเพียงตีนแนะนำอีกอย่างหนึ่ง
ที่คิดว่าทุกคนนักเรียนทุกคนน้องเรียกก็
ต้องรู้จักอ่ารู้จักแน่นอนอันนี้นี่คือ
นี่คืออะไรครับ
ผัดถ่ายแล้วนี่คือผัดไทยอ่ะผัดไทยผัดไทย
หลายๆคนในโลกรู้จักผัดไทยเพราะว่ามันมี
ชื่อเหมือนกับประเทศไทยอ่ะมันคือผัดไทย
อ่ะผัดไทยอันนี้เป็นผัดไทยกุ้งผัดไทยกุ้ง
ใช่ครับเราสามารถเลือกได้เหมือนกันว่าจะ
กินผัดไทยกุ้งผัดไทยปลาหมึกผัดไทยอ่ะหนู
อัดไทยไก่ก็ได้นะครับนะแต่ว่าโดยส่วนใหญ่
ถ้าเราไม่บอกถ้าเราไม่บอกเขาจะใส่กุ้งมา
ให้
5 อย่าๆนี่เป็นผัดไทยในผัดไทยก็จะมี
มะนาวมีแฟนมะนาวมะนาวมีรถเป็นไงครับมะนาว
ใส่มะนาวทำไม
เที่ยวใส่มะนาวเพื่อเพิ่มรสเปรี้ยวลงไปใน
คัดไทยว้าวเติมรสเปรี้ยวเข้าไปนะครับอ่ะ
แล้วก็อะที่นอกจากมีผัดไทยแล้วนับในร้าน
อาหารตามสั่งก็ยังมีอันนี้ด้วยครับนี่
หน้าตาคล้ายๆกับผัดไทยแต่ไม่เหมือนกันไม่
เหมือนกันสร้างอันนี้เรียกผัดอะไรครับใช่
แล้วผัดซีอิ๊วครับนี่อัดซีอิ้วก็จะมีหมู
มีไข่ด้วยแล้วก็มีผักเป็นผัดซีอิ๊วโอ้นะ
ครับทัสยุก็ไม่เผ็ดนะไม่เผ็ดนะแต่ถ้าใคร
ที่ชอบกินเผ็ดเราก็ใส่พริกลงไปได้อันนี้
พริกอยู่ตรงนี้จะมีน้ำตาลๆมีน้ำตาลเพิ่ม
ความหวานนะเพิ่มมะนาวเพิ่มรสเปรี้ยวเข้า
ไปให้ 5 ผัดซีอิ๊วหน้าคิมหาพี่ตอนนี้รู้
สึกหิวแล้วใช่มั้ยน้องเหมียวหิวแล้วอยาก
ให้อยากให้เที่ยงเร็วๆอยากให้ถึงตอน
เที่ยงเร็วๆจะแดกไปกินผัดซีอิ้วกันนะแค่
ไหนเอา
ๆๆเดี๋ยวนะๆนอกจาก
นะตอนเช้าตอนเช้ากินข้าวแกงแล้วใช่ไหมตอน
เที่ยงนี้ค่ะคำสั่งแล้วตอนเย็นล่ะตอนเย็น
เราจะไปกินอะไรกันดีตอนเย็น
ตอนเย็นเดี๋ยวเราเจอกันตอนเย็นเนี่ย
ประมาณ 5 โมงไหม
17:00 นเย็นใช่ 5 โมงเย็นน่ะ 17:00 นตรง
นะ 5 โมงตรง
17:00 น
ใช่เราก็จะไปกินข้าวเย็นออกมาก็ไปกินข้าว
เย็นหน้าว่าวันนี้กินข้าว 3 มื้อเลยมื้อ
เช้ามื้อที่เที่ยงแล้วก็มื้อเย็นนะโอเค
เข้าเย็นเดี๋ยวเปียตีจะพาไปกิน
ก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวๆอ้ามีก๋วยเตี๋ยวเยอะเลยพี่
ประเทศไทยเป็นร้านที่อยู่ริมทางหน้าซี
ฟู้ดริมทางมีร้านก๋วยเตี๋ยว 5 เดี๋ยวพี่
เปี๊ยกว่านั้นก๋วยเตี๋ยวอ้าๆใช่หรือเรา
พูดง่ายๆว่าไปกินก๋วยเตี๋ยว
เอ่อเดี๋ยวเย็นนี้เย็นนี้เย็นนี้เย็นนี้
นะเย็นนี้ไปกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวกันอ่ะโอเคไปกิน
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวกันนี่นี่ครับก๋วยเตียวอันนี้
เป็นก๋วยเตี๋ยวเส้นเล็ก
เส้นเล็กเส้นเล็กนี่ครับนี้คือเส้นเส้น
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวเส้นจะเป็นถ้าเป็นแบบนี้เป็น
เส้นเส้นแบบนี้อาจเป็นเส้นมีเส้นขนาดเล็ก
นี่เส้นขนาดเล็กเป็นเส้น
อันเล็กใช่ใช่ครับนี่คือก๋วยเตี๋ยวเต้น
เล็กตรงนี้เราก็เรียกเป็นเส้นผมๆเป็นเส้น
เหมือนกันเห็นๆครับเช่นนั้นเป็นเส้นผม
ส่วนอันนี้เป็นเส้นก๋วยเตี๋ยวอ่า
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวเส้นเล็กๆแบบนี้หน้าตาแบบนี้
เรียกว่าเส้นเล็กนอกจากมีเส้นเล็กแล้วยัง
มีเส้นใหญ่ด้วยนะบางคนบางคนก็ชอบกินเส้น
ใหญ่ใช่เส้นจะใหญ่เส้นจะใหญ่หลักนี้ครับ
หน้านี่เป็นเส้นก็จะเดินแผ่นแบนๆใหญ่ๆนิ
อ้านี่ครับเส้นใหญ่เส้นจะใหญ่กว่าถ้าเส้น
เล็กเส้นจะเล็กแบบนี้อ้านี่คือเส้นเล็ก
แต่อันนี้อันนี้ครับนี้เส้นใหญ่อีกใหญ่
อ้าวเส้นใหญ่มีก๋วยเตี๋ยวเส้นเล็กเส้น
ใหญ่ช่วงเวลาที่เราไปสั่งก๋วยเตี๋ยวสั่ง
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวคนหายจะถามเราถามแล้วเอาเส้น
เล็กหรือเส้นใหญ่หน้าหรือบางครั้งคนขายก็
จะถามว่าเอาเส้นอะไรเส้นอะไรครับเส้นอะไร
ดีอะไรคะใช่เอาเส้นอะไรครับเราก็ต้องตอบ
เราก็ต้องตอบว่าเขาเส้นเล็กหรือเส้นใหญ่
หรือหรือยังมีเส้นอยู่อีกมีเส้นหลายแบบ
มาก 5 มีอะไรคะพี่มีเส้นนี้มีเส้นนี้เป็น
เส้นเล็กกว่าเล็กกว่าเส้นเล็กหน้าเล็ก
กว่านี้เรียกว่าเส้นหมี่
เส้นหมี่เส้นเล็กลงเล็กลงอีกเล็กกว่าเส้น
เล็กเป็นเส้นหมี่อ่า
เอาเส้นอะไรเรียบ
ครับเล่นเห็น
อยู่ในชามอ่า 5 กลมอันนี้เรียกว่าลูกชิ้น
อ่าอันนี้เป็นลูกชิ้นโอ้ว้าวเราก็สั่งเลย
ว่าเอาเส้นหมี่ลูกชิ้นน่ะเอาลูกชิ้นด้วย
นะครับแล้วก็มีหมูอันนี้เป็นหมูไหมครับ
อาบังร้านเราก็จะเลือกได้ว่าเอาหมูไหม
หรือไม่เอาถ้าไม่เอาเอารูปที่เอาลูกชิม
เอาลูกชิ้นเยอะหมูไม่เอาอะหรือว่าเอาหมู
อย่างเดียวเพราะหมูอย่างเดียวไม่เอาลูก
ชิ้นก็ได้ก็ได้ใช่ครับเราต้องบอกเราต้อง
บอกถ้าไม่บอกถ้าไม่บอกเขาจะใส่ให้ทุก
อย่างเลยใส่หมูด้วยใส่ลูกชิ้นด้วยถ้าไม่
บอกหน้าแต่ถ้าบอกเขาก็จะใส่ตามที่เราอยาก
ได้อ่าโอเคนอกจากเส้นหมี่แล้วยังมีอีกยัง
มีอีกใช่ครับเราต้องเลือกอะไรต้องเลือก
ให้ถูกไว้อยากกินอะไรอ่ะเส้น
นี้สีเหลืองนี่เป็นเส้นสีเหลืองโอ้นี่
เรียกว่าบะหมี่เส้นบะหมี่น้าโอเคเวลาเดิน
เข้าไปในร้านคนขายถามว่าเอาเส้น ID ครับ
งานน้องเรียนตอบว่าเอาบะหมี่ค่ะอ้าวโอเค
เอาบะหมี่ก็จะได้เป็นสีเหลืองแบบนี้อ้า
บะหมี่เส้นบะหมี่ทำมาจากไข่ไข่อ้าทำมาจาก
ไข่เป็นบะหมี่ที่นี่นอกจากยังไม่เห็นยัง
ไม่ได้กินง่ายๆนะของสั่ง
ทองสร้างอีกว่าจะเอาอ่าอ่า
แห้งหรือว่าน้ำแบบมีน้ำซุปค่ะนี่เป็นน้ำ
ซุป
นะมีน้ำซุปมีแบบแห้งด้วยแบบแห้งก็คือแบบ
นี้จะไม่มีน้ำซุ้มอ่ะ
ๆไม่มีน้ำแล้วสั่งเส้นเล็กแห้งเส้นใหญ่
น้ำหน้าบะหมี่แห้งบะหมี่มีน้ำใจเราต้อง
บอกต้องบอกว่าจะเอาแบบไหนเออใช่ครับแต่
ถ้าเราสั่งบะหมี่แห้งเนี่ยเขาก็จะมีน้ำ
ซุปมาให้ด้วยมีน้ำซุปแยกมาไม่ใส่รวมกันนะ
ไม่รวมกันไม่รวมกันเขาได้แยกมาน้ำซุป 1
ถ้วยบะหมี่แห้งอีก 1 ถ้วยนะเวลาที่เรากิน
เราก็จริงผู้กันได้ใช่ใช้ค่าไม่แห้งเขาจะ
เอามาให้เราแบบไหนคะทำเอาแบบหมายถึงถ้า
ไม่สั่งถ้าไม่บอกถ้าไม่บอกอะไรเราจะได้
แบบมีน้ำซุปเราจะได้แบบนี้เราจะได้แบบมี
น้ำซุปถ้าไม่สั่งถ้าไม่พูดกันๆทรายๆครับ
แต่ถ้าเราอยากกินแยกกันเราต้องบอกว่าเอา
เอาบะหมี่แห้งเอาเส้นหมี่แห้งเขาก็จะแยก
มาให้ถ้าไม่บอกเขาจะรวมกันมา
ใต้ K
นะครับแล้วก็อ่ะอ่ะ
ค่ะวันนี้โอ้โหได้หรือยังค่ะ
อยากไปกินแล้วใช่ไหมยังไม่เที่ยงเลยยัง
ไม่เที่ยงเลยนี่พึ่งจะ 10 โมงอยากกินแล้ว
แมะ
น่ากินแล้วใช่ไหมโอเคถ้าอย่างงั้นเดี๋ยว
วันนี้เดี๋ยวขอตัวอ่ะตี้กับอ่าน้อง
เรียมขอตัวพาไปกินข้าวข้าวอย่าลืมนะสั่ง
ให้ถูกต้องที่อยากจะกินนะจะกินเผ็ดไหม
หรือไม่เผ็ดอะต้องบอกของเบาะแล้วแกครับ
แล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเขาหน้าเรามาดูกันว่า
น้องเรียมนักเรียนทุกคนนะได้ไปสั่งอาหาร
แบบไหนนะที่ท่อไปค่ะกันแล้วเดี๋ยวมาเล่า
ให้ฟังหรือว่าคีย์ใส่คอมเม้นไว้นะครับนัก
เรียนทีคอมเมนต์ใส่ไว้ว่าก็แค่เคยกินผัด
ไทยอ่ะเคยกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวแห้งหน้าเคยกินผัด
กระเพราก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเพียบอาหมวยอาว่า
ชอบไหมเอาอะไรน่ะใช่หรือว่าเคยไปร้านตาม
สั่งไปสั่งผัดกระเพราหมูอาหารผัดกระเพรา
ไก่
มาบอกกันนะคะให้มาเล่าให้ฟังในคอมเม้น
ข้างล่างเดี๋ยวเปียตีกับน้องเรียมจะเข้า
ไปดูนะครับโอเคทราบวันนี้ขอบคุณทุกคนนะ
ครับที่อ่ะมาเรียนรู้ภาษาไทยกันนะครับ
แล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเราจะพาไปไหนนะครับคอย
ติดตามกันวันนี้สวัสดีครับสวัสดีสวัสดี
ค่ะพี่นะพี่สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนครับเทียน
กระเพราไก่ไข่ดาว
โอเคเอาบะหมี่แห้งไหมครับหนึ่งที่บ๊ายบาย
น